it was all all in the Market Square
hundreds of people strugged down that
side more or less where the middle of
the road is going up there between the
yellow lines so quite an event they live
in 1953. I think it brought all your
community together you never were really
split up what denomination you were
what age you were you were all brought
together and you all celebrated it from
youngsters or I took to grandparents age
so it was well well attended on the day
Millions will Mark the crowning of a new
monarch in their local communities John
can remember the same moment 70 years
ago he was part of a parade in his home
of settle North Yorkshire winning first
prize for his costume Nana road we
danced mum she made the costume out of
any sort of material that she had
available and was suitable after another
milestone in British history he thinks
protecting and preserving are links to
the Past are important it's bringing all
your memories back
and you can share uh that day with
whoever you're talking to when our
family come up and our grandchildren and
they say what did you do when you did
shorts or Granddad and I say well just
to me we'll get to Portugal and I'll
show you so I can pass for information
on to another two generations down there
are not a lot of people living locally
who actually will remember these events
so it's nice to have it documented
in these communities they've long
celebrated jubilees and coronations for
a king well known as a champion of the
countryside they want those Traditions
to continue
the best one from 1935 I think showing
the the banner there God bless our King
first made for George V for the last 70
years these banners were used for the
queen in nearby land cliff now the
original wording is back on display I
was blown away by them because I just
they're they're so wonderful really that
we've still got them after all this time
uh yeah there's a sense of time very
much in those photos and and now I
suspect yes we will celebrate but it
won't it's it's not going to be on the
same scale I'm afraid we're not not
doing so much
however people choose to celebrate
stories from this weekend will be told
for generations to come shinki marike
Sky News North Yorkshire